check is the word that is used when one
piece is threatening to capture the
other side's King check basically means
look out King in danger let's take a
look at some examples of playing check
in this position can you see how white
can threaten to capture the black King
that's right
Bishop to f6 check White's Bishop puts
the black King in danger of capture so
black must deal with this check in the
next lesson we'll learn about the three
ways of getting out of check in this
position blacks rook can put White's
King into danger after rook d1 the white
king is in check and white must respond
to this attack finally in this position
black's pawn is ready to capture the
white knight remember pawns capture one
square away diagonally can you see how
white can escape the pawns attack and
place the black King into check if you
found Knight to g6 great job the knight
escapes danger and now puts the black
King into check one final question is
how do we notate a check it is pretty
easy all you do is add a plus to the end
of your typical move notation this means
after writing n g6 you add a plus at the
end so it'll look like this ng 6 plus
meaning that black is in check now it's
your turn to practice playing check